[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right thank you everyone for coming
to cloud native data pipelines my name
is Sid Anand to start off with I'll tell
you a bit about me I've been in the area
for about 15 years most of my time has
been spent building end-to-end data
infrastructure at companies that
operated scale so those include LinkedIn
Netflix eBay and Etsy for the last two
years I've been working at a security
sass start-up called AG re and they're
doing some pretty interesting things
with data in the cloud and that's what
I'd like to talk to you about today in
my spare time I'm a co-chair for Q con
SF and London I'm also a committer and
ppm C member on Apache airflow a project
that is was created by the person
following me max Maxie Maxie Murray here
there he is
alright and I'm a father of two you a
four-year-old boy and a six month old
girl so for those of you not familiar
with the Gauri what does a Gauri do we
make email safe again and for those of
you who are familiar with email it's
actually never been safe
it's like SMTP has been around since the
70s and it's only more recently that
security protocols like SPF D Kim and D
mark have gained some adoption but it's
definitely not widespread
so we are still living in this world
where you get an email from your credit
card company telling you that there's a
suspicious charge and you're about to be
locked out of your account and before
you know it you can type in your
password and you get fished so seven
years ago when the guard launched they
were trying to solve this problem and
most of my previous companies those
include you know you know eBay LinkedIn
Netflix they all had consumers right and
they didn't want those consumers to be
fished by emails pretending to be from
them so a gaara's first product was like
solving this problem when I joined two
years ago
they wanted to solve the problem that
businesses are facing and so if you
remember LinkedIn a few years ago like
lost 17 million password
it's and that came through some sort of
email route so the the product that you
know when I joined that we started
building is a way to stop what we call
like zero day email attacks which are
just you know very targeted fish emails
with no prior signatures so how do we
solve this problem our first version of
this problem or product was a visibility
product so what that essentially meant
is we had customers that would deploy
our docker based like email sensor in
their enterprise so on premise and as
they got mail into their email
infrastructure they would send us the
headers just the headers and they would
send it to us in a batch like every 15
minutes a new file drop would happen on
s3 and we're running in the cloud so we
would read that data we'd build some
trust model we'd score the data as on a
scale of trusted nests and we just you
know put it up on our website and show
them a view of their mail flow like how
much email or the getting that was sort
of like fishy about a year ago we
developed a near real-time product that
instead of getting batches of this we're
just getting streaming metadata all the
time and we continue to show this
visibility into their mail flow in real
time but we also have a control system
that will take action and eliminate
those emails and it's pretty interesting
because you know we are running
something in the cloud we get it and
we're actually taking action on a docker
container in on premise and end-to-end
five-nines we're doing it in like three
seconds and most of that traffic is
happening over the public Internet are
like near real-time pipeline has to be
just really far and always fast so
that's a really key part of this system
so pretty much everyone here has
experience with data pipelines and data
ends tend to fall in like two categories
VI and predictive so let's say you work
at Spotify or Netflix and your customers
are interacting with your website and as
your customers interact with your
website data is being stored in some
sort of oil TPE database and that
database could be my sequel Oracle or
Cassandra and everyday data will get
pulled out of that database as part of
some ETL loaded it into a data warehouse
and that data warehouse combined with
maybe Kafka tracking data will well you
know give your business insight into
what's happening so it'll you know
usually be fed into some sort of
reporting or your business analysts will
use some sort of query browser to to
query and analyze that data that's like
a typical like for house use case this
is intelligent
another interesting type of pipe
pipeline is a predictive data pipeline
and this is pretty common as well
essentially you have some sort of data
source the data source could be data at
rest or it could be streaming data and
you have you have some sort of
processing framework flink beam storm
spark what-have-you and this framework
will take that data and do something
interesting with it like it will rank it
it will personalize it to get get a
subset of the data that's personalized
to each end user it may also generate it
may also categorize the data and the
result of those computations will be
stored in some sort of cash either Redis
or it will be stored in a you know
really fast data store on a cassandra or
maybe just database a coracle and then
web servers will serve this as a data
product right and you've seen these data
products like every day so if you
visited like Netflix or Spotify the data
products that you that are the output of
this data pipeline would be content
recommendations like here's a movie you
might like here's a song you should
listen to if you're using Facebook
or LinkedIn you'll get Network
recommendations IQ someone here's
someone you should follow if you're
buying something online in Amazon or
Ebay you'll get item recommendations
like people who bought this also buy
this right and then every search engine
also is a great example of recommender
systems because the ranking in there is
done through some sort of recommendation
now what we are actually working on at
Gauri is recommender systems per se it's
actually fraud prevention and that's
another you know typical use case of
data pipelines right
whether it's iTunes looking for a weird
purchases they have a fraud prevention
pipeline we also have a fraud prevention
pipeline looking for as your de email
attack and taking it out before it free
click on it now what do I mean by cloud
native data pipelines right so if you
work at you know a large company you
know LinkedIn it actually many companies
that run say in a data center they have
very large data infrastructure teams the
teams of 200 right like the like the
cassandra team at Apple is bigger than
all of the garbage engineering right so
why did you have these teams well if you
look at data engineering teams they're
essentially a team of specialists right
typical deployments would have like
Sandra perhaps or HBase spark or flink
Kafka elasticsearch and all of these are
pretty complicated beasts and you need
you know not just one expert sometimes
you need to to really understand and
tune what what's going on when things go
bad when when data grows to a scale that
it doesn't work a gory can't really hot
you know do that right we have so many
technologies and Sofia engineers and we
burn everyone out with you know
operational fatigue so we you know what
can we do given that you know we operate
in the cloud like most startups and the
idea is that there are some cloud native
techniques and you know of course when
the
us don't work for us we adopt some sort
of open-source technology that we will
become experts on and we'll try to get
the same sort of guarantees that like
big data companies can get from their
data pipelines and you know when
possible we'll go for a hosted solution
and when not possible you know we'll
become experts in that open source
technology so when building a data
pipeline what are some desirable
qualities to make it fault-tolerant and
you know operable for us it's
correctness timeliness cost and
operability so what does that mean so
for correctness it means that there's
data integrity and to end we don't lose
data
we don't corrupt data also if we're
running a predictive data pipeline it
means that we're getting personalized or
score data and so we'd expect over time
that the the distribution of those
scores is at least what we expect and it
shouldn't change too much it should be
somewhat stable from a timeliness
perspective whether you're running a
daily batch or an hourly batch or like
near real-time the pipeline needs to
stick to it SLA is from operability
perspective from the operability
perspective it's like really really key
to to avoid operational fatigue right
you have these are very specialized data
engineers is they're really smart and
they shouldn't spend all of their time
keeping your service up and if you work
at these like larger companies you'll
find that there's a lot of operational
fatigue many of these engineers are just
spending 90% of the time keeping things
running and in addition we need some
sort of monitoring and alerting you know
because we we need to check if we're
sticking to our correctness and
timeliness SLA and finally in a quick
recoverability there's this interesting
comparison between like a jeep and like
a Bentley I guess or rolls-royce and
essentially
rolls-royce's are highly like really
well designed to work on you know roads
right but if you take them out of there
you know operational design constraints
like let's say it's like a really wet
road or you have to go through mud or up
a hill they break down and when they
break down you've got to fix it and
fixing it is a lengthy process so they
really design for what's called
mtbf or mean time between failures the
they're designed to and actually took
the slide out for time but my pocket
should have kept it in but essentially
they're designed for to not fail but if
they're ever pushed outside of their
design criteria there's a lengthy
process to fix Rolls Royce where the
Jeep the you know it's designed to be
beat-up and they're designed for what's
called MTTR
mean time to recovery so they're
designed to be pushed beyond the limits
breakdown and be quickly fixable so for
us that we want something designed for
MTTR we want to automate everything but
whenever something happens that we
didn't expect fix it quickly and if you
work on the data pipeline let me just
get a set of hands how many of you
actually maintain or work on data
pipelines alright so how many of you
understand or have encountered that when
there's a bug you don't have to just fix
the bug but fix all the downstream data
you've corrupted or lost right and
that's sort of the operational fatigue
that people run into so we need a system
that is quickly recoverable for that use
case and finally cost pay-as-you-go so
as I mentioned we have a few different
use cases the ones I'm actually going to
be talking about today it's called
message scoring I'm not going to talk
too much about model building just once
models are built how we use it for
message scoring in both our batch and
Narottam architectures so let's jump
into our batch of pipeline architecture
so we have these customers they've all
installed a sensor and these sensors are
getting mail flow and uploading
file every 15 minutes to s3 we have an
airflow job that will kick off spark at
the top of every hour and that job will
read this input data score it and
generate some sort of aggregates when
it's done it'll write it back to s3 and
we have as we set up with what's called
SNS sqs notification essentially every
object we put will send this the new
file notification to SNS that will get
queued up in simple queue service which
is Amazon's sqs when that happens we
automatically spin up through an auto
scaling group a group of what we call
importers and their job is to take this
data clean it in some way and load it
into you our Postgres database so as
three sort of hold all of our data but a
small portion of our data is loaded into
a database because that's really what
our rails web app is going to show to
our users for a visibility product so
this is our architecture and we use air
flow to manage everything that's an
orange so that's our workflow engine for
this like batch use case so I'm not
going to walk through every item on this
list but sort of these are the
architectural components and when we
were picking these components we
leverage things that were like
surveillance or what we call manage so
that we don't have that headache but
when we thought we didn't find an
adequate solution in Amazon that's when
we decided to operate it ourselves
so for example if you're running in your
own data center how many of you actually
run in your own data center versus the
cloud raise your hand if you run in your
own data center it does everyone else
use the
okay so most of you already use the
cloud so s3 is sort of our HDFS right
it's what we put all input data all
intermediate data all final output data
it's scalable available performance we
never have to really worry about it
whereas if we ran our own HDFS cluster
we would we would have to worry about it
and and basically growing it and scaling
it keeping it up and you know so that's
one of them and then for SNF block ask
us that combination before Kinesis was
really I would say a production ready we
we actually picked this it's a like a
reliable transactional pub/sub model
it's really good and it's work really
well for us and it's super cheap and
then for processing we have two types we
have sort of like the typical data
science processing which would in our
case be scoring model building
aggregation and you know SPARC is
awesome in the sense that it has this
like really nice programming model but
it's really complicated very hard to
debug especially for things like
performance and it's very easy to get
yourself into a problem where you've got
a very complex diagram and you can
figure out why your job is taking so
long but first more simple type of
processing we use in an auto scale group
of of instances and as I mentioned we
use airflow for all of our spark jobs
and complex flows it's like it it uses
instead it users can configure code that
model so all the workflows are actually
defined in code so you can sort of put
that code through your normal code
development pipeline and it does have a
steep learning curve when it comes to
operability air flow isn't very
opinionated about how its operated
that's something outside is like what
we've actually defined for it and it is
something that people run into and
finally we use postgrads for no better
reason
but the rails developer spec Postgres
before the data pipe on an engineer
joined the company so we use Postgres we
operate those three but we're you know
as I talk about our near real-time
pipeline I'm going to show you some of
the cool things that we've done to move
away from it so how do we tackle cost
and timeliness so when we were running
daily our architecture was designed to
be low cost what does that mean so for
the things I mentioned there are things
we operate what that essentially means
is we're running it on an ec2 instance
all of the time so here that's the
database a web app and our airflow
server but everything else doesn't cost
us anything for 23 hours of the day at
the end of the day we did a nightly run
and at that point we spun at the EMR as
messages got pushed in the pipeline our
importers got spun up from zero and we
paid for one hour of work and that was
it and that was a good cost saving well
we took this too and we just changed air
flow to run from delay to hourly and we
saved nothing in terms of cost because
if you know something about ec2 they
charge you at the our boundary and even
if we took 10 minutes to do all our work
we were paying for the full hour so this
really wasn't a cost saving if you're
familiar with lambdas anything that you
can move to lambda you should because
they charge you up to 100 milliseconds
so if you take 200 milliseconds you just
pay for those 200 milliseconds if you
take 201 milliseconds you're paying for
300 milliseconds it's vastly cheaper
than the typical ec2 model for compute
how about timeliness um how many of you
have used auto scaling just a show of
hands okay so maybe seven or eight
people so auto scaling there's two ways
we handle timeliness first of all for
the SPARC side if we want a spark job to
get faster one option is to throw more
resources at it and because we have air
flow spin it up it's just a matter of a
config of how many like workers we want
to spin up and flow before the run
starts spin up an EMR cluster to that
size and we
the kind of we expect for our more
general processing we use an auto
scaling group like these importance and
essentially the idea is as messages show
up on sqs we should scale these
importers out to to more quickly import
them into our database why is this
important so in our hourly pipeline
sometimes our spark jobs would take 50
minutes which meant that we only had a
time budget of under 10 minutes to
import all of them into the database
this is where the importer is really
shine regardless of what was happening
with our spark job we could just
increase you know change the max value
for these auto scale groups to increase
the speed or throughput into our
database for importing so our first
model for auto scaling was to use what's
called a CPU based trigger so what this
really means is with an auto scaler you
provide some sort of out policy and a
scale in policy so for us we said the
thing that we're scaling out look at the
average CPU of that thing of the cluster
and if it goes above 40% average CPU
grow it out like add another machine to
the cluster just try to maintain 40% CPU
on average okay so the graph at the
bottom shows that for the cluster as
it's going through scaling in and out
the autoscaler is really good at
sticking at 40% and that's what what
this is it's basically right around 40%
now let's look at these graphs so this
right here is the message message rate
going into our sq sq that's coming from
spark and now we start off with zero
importers and now as messages are going
this is the messages being consumed by
our importers and this is the total CPU
of the ASE cluster it's going up
linearly so what's happening is the
autoscaler starts at zero and then you
start adding machines in these little
steps and as
does so it's improving its increasing
the rate of consuming these messages and
then it spins up the cluster to a max
size and when there no message is left
it spins the cluster down and all the
while it's only goal is to try to stick
at 40% CPU on average and it's excellent
at doing that there is a problem and the
problem is that right here we get what's
called premature scaling so when there
are like say more machines then messages
on as sqs the CPU drops dramatically
there's exactly one message left on sqs
just one message or like a batch so one
message left and then what's going to
happen is the autoscaler is going to
start scaling in kind of at random and
it may pick the one machine that's
processing that one message and that one
message will actually never get
processed because you have no control
about which machine is going to get
scaled in so this was the problem with
using CPU it there were different
approaches like you know just sort of
wait a really long time for the signal
but there was not like really a great
method to solve this problem when we
were just using average CPU but if this
was really more of an i/o bound kind of
process and CPU wasn't really a great
measure so the approach we took was to
use queue based scaling so how many of
you have used sqs okay a few of you
maybe five so sqs has two metrics one
metric is the count of visible messages
those are the ones you can get and then
once you get message it becomes
invisible
it becomes an in-flight message so for
the in-flight messages you get a
separate thing called the invisible
message count so what we do is we used
the scale out policy is based only on
visible messages that's the blue line so
over time messages are being added by
the Vice Park so the count of messages
goes up to the peak and of course as we
start consuming the messages here this
starts dropping until Z
actually this is really sorry this is
approximate number of messages visible
so now all of these messages this is
just basically the number of visible
messages and at this point all of the
messages are in flight there are no more
messages that are visible they're all in
flight but they're being processed and
that's taking some amount of time so we
keep scaling out as long as this blue
line is above zero
that helps us scale out to a maximum
size and then we watch this orange curve
and this orange curve is invisible
message count and that's like insight
messages when we get so when we get to
this point all the messages are
currently in process we're actually
processing them and then as they get
finished or completed this orange curve
drops to zero and that means everything
the last message has been processed
successfully and when that happens we
scale in from you know 25 mils to hero
in a snap so this completely worked for
us and there wasn't really a blog about
this anywhere it wasn't even like kind
of mentioned in Amazon about queue
scaling but this turned out to be a
great help to us so when talking about
auto scaling some people ask how do we
do it so we are big proponents of
terraform ansible and packer so just to
get a sense of of people what they use
how many of you use terraform okay some
really events how many of you use
ansible okay and what about Packer
I probably the same person all right
okay so terraform is what you use to
declaratively spin up like like Amazon
instance on resources like SQS Kinesis
et tu aSG's all of that stuff ansible is
what you use it's sort of a replacement
for chef and puppet it's a way to
install the packages you need on a given
instance so for example it's like sci-fi
or pandas or scikit-learn like all of
those things are things you may install
on a machine so that you could use it
for some interesting like data science
right you'd use ansible to declaratively
specify on a like fresh machine
packages to install and Parker is this
other thing that is used what's called
like create what's called an ami an
Amazon machine image so let's get a
sense of how we use it
step one Packers spins up a temporary
ec2 note and that's a blank canvas it's
just spinning up an ec2 note step 2
it runs our ansible playbook to install
all of the stuff like all the Ruby
packages or Python packages or Java
packages we need to run the business
logic and get the server up and running
step 3 we snapshot the ec2 instance to
get an ami and we no longer need this
temporary instance we tear it down
Packer just destroys it the result is we
got an image why do we care about an
image well terraform will take this
image and it will deploy an auto scaling
group of this image so we're not really
managing servers at this point we're
just building these a.m. eyes and
telling amazon's auto scaling group you
manage these servers using these a.m. is
the other technique we're following in
some places is to use lambdas another
thing is and I'll talk about this a bit
later but like our company of 20 people
codes and for languages so we have
services in node Ruby Python and Java
and lambda doesn't support Ruby so we're
still using this approach for our Ruby
jobs like our server let's approach to
like Ruby and for the others we're
moving those to lambda so we've sort of
talked about the timeliness and cost
what about the other two
so with data pipelines automation is key
right so we don't want to we want
something where we can manage and
configure an author workflows very
simply we need visibility into how our
workflows are running and we need like
good integration with our alerting and
monitoring tools
and about two years ago I went to a talk
that max was giving and and I we came up
we were looking for the solution and
Amazon didn't have a good one and Apache
airflow is what we actually settled on
it it basically helps you define
workflows as like Python code
if you've used other things like loozy
defined in XML or azkaban it's just like
a bunch of zip files and maybe yamo
files it's quite terrible and just like
being able to write stuff in code is
really great things like Luigi also
support this and then you can visually
see your workflow so this is sort of the
workflow that's managing this data
pipeline and it's very easy to manage
multiple pipelines and you can pause
some of them some of these are on some
are paused they have different types of
schedules like we support like cron
syntax as well as like you can use like
Python time Delta you can also specify
some built-in ones like hourly daily I
guess monthly must be one and we get
like at a glance statistics or statuses
on how many of our runs are successful
or in progress or failing it's very easy
to manage workflows before this we were
using cron it was a quite a nightmare
and if you want to see for a given run
what's taking the longest time that's
also easy with the Gantt chart and this
essentially shows you that our our total
run was 18 minutes for an hourly run it
took 18 minutes to do one an hourly run
and of course we paid for the full hour
and of that time the SPARC job took 10
minutes and the importing took I don't
know what does it say like a minute or
two minutes so the import took about two
minutes to complete and the SPARC job
took about 10 minutes now the next
question might be does it always run
like this and the and the answer to that
is no it doesn't because we're
constantly modifying the spot job and
we're also seeing an increase in like
data growth so it's good to see a time
oriented view of the performance
and here's a great example are this this
is the our spark job and is always
taking the most time this the spark task
is always taking the most time in our
job and at one point over four weeks it
was taking longer every time it ran so
we had a bug and it's creeping up into
this 0.55 or essentially this is half an
hour right it was taking you know 20
minutes and it's now beating over half
an hour and it turned out it turned out
to be a bug we fixed it and we brought
the time back and we did more
optimization and brought it back and we
did more optimization and brought it
down and then of course we broke
something or added some new feature
calculation and it went up again but
this really helps us keep track of
whether we're on our SL A's
finally we use slack and Victor ops and
it's very easy to integrate air flow
with these so anytime we're missing our
time SLA or we're getting discrepancies
we get paged and we get a link pasted
into our slack window and when we click
on it we can see for example for this
customer this org ID 54 we were getting
60% data loss all of a sudden we were
paid fixed it and it went away
it's just very easy to help us run
operations so we sort of talked about
the back side of things what about the
near real-time side of things so similar
to before our enterprises are running
collectors those collectors are setting
up data now they're sending it over
Kinesis which is essentially amazon's
answer to Kafka and we have scorers
running that are scoring this data in an
auto scaling group and they write their
score output message by message to
Kinesis and then we have importers
reading from Kinesis and writing it to
our database and we also have a separate
service called an alert ER and that
alerter is getting these messages and
sort of quarantine in the email and this
whole pipeline runs in under a couple of
seconds so I'm not going to go over
every single thing on here but I think
the most important takeaway is right
Kinesis versus Kafka so
we don't have enough people to like
manage Casca and Casca can be something
that's difficult to manage
so Kinesis actually works quite well for
us land reverses ASG so as i mentioned
we're going towards lambda it's cheaper
for us it's you know you only pay up to
100 millisecond mark and you know we run
Python Java note those are run in
lambdas but like our Ruby jobs are still
running in this ASG model an important
an important thing to understand here is
when we went from hourly to
near-real-time
we thought we could just take our spark
job and just like basically implement
the the real-time micro batching and
that didn't work essentially the jobs
were so complicated okay the jobs are so
complicated that the we couldn't get
stuff done within a five-minute window
because the jobs are written for bash
that take an hour and they were okay
with taking half an hour and those
complex computations couldn't just they
had to be completely rewritten - to
support like micro batching in under a
few seconds so essentially we were the
best we could do in the next five
minutes and for a near all-time pipeline
that's not at all near real-time so we
essentially took out the scoring from
spark and we just use part four model
builds that's all it does now and
another really interesting thing here is
we used to do pre aggregation in our
database that doesn't really work for
near real-time pipelines because data
comes late and because it's late arrival
data your aggregates are always off so
we essentially took we killed pre
aggregation we replaced our application
in Postgres with elasticsearch and we do
real time on the fly aggregation and it
turned out to just work perfectly how
are you I never has discrepancies we'd
never have late arrival data and it's
actually faster and another thing was
our data science workloads we're doing
window like window functions and we
needed
database to do that and Postgres was too
slow for a near real-time batch sorry
near real-time processing pipeline so we
just replace it with Redis so we
essentially took out a lot of the stuff
we used to throw at Postgres and I guess
one other thing is search and we moved
it to like a polyglot persistence model
our NIA are like data science is hitting
Redis for the real-time batch our web
app is doing searches and aggregates now
against a real-time engine which is
elastic search and we're only using
Postgres as a place to put detailed
information and that's it and this model
has really worked for us so I'm going to
kind of speed up a little because we
might be running out of time but this is
the last major part of my talk I'm Avro
so how many of you use Avro not even
half okay so Avro is so when you think
about data at rest typically you think
about data in a database right and that
data has a schema and when you start
interacting with the data that schema
ensures that data doesn't get corrupt
what about two jobs that communicate
through a file on the system where is
there any sort of integrity check well
that's where Avro comes in Avro is a
schema on top of a file at rest right so
and it supports primitive data types
it supports complex nested data types
and it has very good language bindings
so we decided that all data at rest and
actually even data that send over stream
should be Avro if it's not in a database
it has to be written in a bro and one
other benefit is scheme evolution them
talk about it so why is Avro useful and
why they useful to us right so as I
mentioned we have these tensors we have
hundreds of customers they're all
running sensors and we can't really
decide when they upgrade their sensors
so at any given time they're running a
different version of the sensor and
different versions of the sensors are
sending different versions of data to us
so in this case v1 v2 v3 what's the
difference
they have different fields and what's
even more complicated at any given time
they're writing to the same Kinesis
stream and we're getting a mix of
versions coming to us and the version
that our servers are running on are a
completely different version version for
Avro actually helps us solve this
problem without ever knowing about this
or worrying about it essentially we do
schema evolution on the fly we never
care what version anyone is running our
code just as the following is writer
schema is the version for I'm sorry a
reader schema is version for it's what
the consumer is compiled against the
writer FEMA is whatever was sent over
the wire to us and the data reader will
do a union and figure out the right
schema to use to analyze the data we
never have an outage we never have to
worry about this it was like the right
decision to go with since beginning and
it's so useful that we don't diffuse it
for data coming from our sensors or IOT
sensors we use it for all data use for
communication between every process or
service running in our pipeline so it's
we decouple all our services to Kinesis
plus Avro and as I mentioned we run four
languages and the language bindings are
actually quite good
we have Java Python Ruby and node and
right now note doesn't use Avro but but
all the others communicates you are oh
no problem and to give you kind of an
example of what an Avro schema looks
like here's one you essentially have a
record call user it has three fields
named favorite number favorite color
it's a record type scheme as the user
typically an Avro is it uses a write the
header to the top of the file and in
this file you have these or datum blocks
which are the records and you could have
a billion or a million of these and the
schema has very little overhead like
0.001 percent on average but what
happens if you send this over the wire
now all of a sudden you're sending one
data in near real-time but the overhead
of the schema is 99
that is way too much so a trip that we
did a LinkedIn and the casco users and
confluent uses is that you don't send
the schema over the wire what you do is
you store it in a registry somewhere you
get an ID out and you just send the ID
like a single number
it's a across wire so we built and we're
going to open source the schema registry
that's based on the lambda and
essentially the producer will get an ID
but when it registers a schema it'll
send the ID with the data the consumer
will read that it'll deserialize it I
mean it will basically get the schema by
ID cache it and then decode the avro and
all of our pipelines save about 99%
throughput and and that's how we get
like quite a high speed in our pipelines
and our schema registry if you remember
this picture is like deployed wherever
we have Kinesis so I think at this point
I'm actually done with the talk
it was probably kind of fast lots of
details if you have further questions
please come and chat with me later
and I'd like to thank my whole team
which is everybody on this slide and
that's it thank you very much